[music]
Jeremy Blair:
This trip began in 2008 when a Princeton professor
and a group of students came to Ashaiman to
Jeremy Blair:
see what the conditions were like and what
the people in the community needed, and they
Jeremy Blair:
made their way to the Evangelical Presbyterian
Church and school complex, and after some
Jeremy Blair:
discussion, decided that a partnership to
build a community library would be helpful
Jeremy Blair:
for both the school and the surrounding community.
So the goal of this trip was really just to transform
Jeremy Blair:
the foundations of a structure into a fully
functioning community library.
Akhil Reddy:
So, my expectations for this trip were really
to just get a lot of hands-on experience with
Akhil Reddy:
basic forms of construction that you usually don't see at Princeton.
Elizabeth O'Grady:
My favorite thing has been seeing the drawings
that we did back at school come to life and
Elizabeth O'Grady:
really take form on a construction site.
Cole Freeman:
I really liked working on the construction
of the building. It's just hands-on engineering
Cole Freeman:
work, and that's a lot of fun.
Jeremy Blair :
It's been really, really interesting to see
how a construction project actually happens.
Jeremy Blair :
It's really different than anything you would
learn in a class, and it's really different
Jeremy Blair :
than something you'd see on TV -- to actually
be on a construction site and see a building
Jeremy Blair :
go from bare foundation to a complete structure
that you can see behind me right now. It's
Jeremy Blair :
definitely a unique experience to be able
to come into a place, really experience it,
Jeremy Blair :
get to know people in the community and leave
a mark on that community.
Akhil Reddy:
I think our project will provide a large amount
of people with access to reading materials,
Akhil Reddy:
education, story books that they didn't have before.
Jeremy Blair :
The building's completed. That's really exciting,
yeah. And so I'm really happy that the project has turned
Jeremy Blair :
out so well.
Buse Aktas:
I think we were a great group. I had a great
time, and everybody should have a similar
Buse Aktas:
experience, I think.
[music]